what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you get decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future it's the one in
normal circumstances we use Thursday as
our day to do like the rundown you know
hey here's a really good story that I
enjoyed I think you guys will enjoy it
too and that kind of crazy thing but
we're actually going to go ahead and
blow that off today just because it's
not nearly as interesting as this in
this video we are going to be running
over the origin of adamantium
specifically the origin of the
adamantium that is bonded to the
skeleton of Wolverine and bonded to the
claws of x-23 because as we'll talk
about in our origin story tomorrow x-23
entire skeleton is not bonded with
adamantium just the claws now this is
going to seem like I kind of come down
to left-field but bear with me for a
second because within the span of four
minutes it's all going to make perfect
sense so the origin of adamantium really
kind of like whines back to the earliest
days of humanity right you know with
this sentient bacteria called Sablan and
sublime was this organism that basically
drive by jumping from one host to the
net but sublime learned pretty fast that
when it jumps to a host it could
basically dominate the will of that host
it could control it that's one of the
reasons why in my video on a history of
the Marvel Universe the other God so
basically waged war against one another
because they were all under the
influence of savlon
but the idea here was that during this
time sublime was basically the dominant
species on the planet Earth there was no
organism that existed on earth that
could resist the will of Sablan now fast
forward to about fifteen thousand years
before the modern day during this time
the planet Earth was one of a multitude
of planets across the universe that were
visited by the Celestials and the
Celestials typically manipulated the
genes of the planet earth to create
three groups eternals deviants and in a
third group we need to worry about
Eternals and mediums for this video but
the third group basically had their
genes modified in such a way that they
went forward appearing to be normal but
the genes were adjusted so that in some
15,000 years there would be this huge
explosion of mutants across the planet
Earth what also happened is the genes
were modified so that if a person was
exposed to some weird kind of situation
for example they were blasted with
cosmic radiation instead of mutating
into some horrendous form they were
suddenly developed hours since the
reason why Peter Parker became
spider-man why
Rogers became Captain America why the
Fantastic Four became the Fantastic Four
now between you know 15,000 years ago
and right now
mutants began popping up periodically
like it would be a mutant would be born
here and then 3,000 years later another
mutant would be born and then 5,000
years after that another mutant would be
born the first of these was a character
named Selene Selene basically had to
kind of feed off the energy feed off the
life force of individuals in order to
keep herself alive there were others who
were born like apocalypse Gideon there
were others like Burke and Kandra but
these were basically what we're called
externals meaning they are inherently
immortal mutants so that if they were to
die if they're you know they were to be
shot in the head or something along
those lines their spiritual essences
would basically live on now that's
assuming you could destroy their
physical bodies for the most part they
were impervious to like normal weapons
you'd have to do something extreme like
The Incredible Hulk would have to rip
their head off or something along those
lines but if their physical bodies were
destroyed then it would basically live
on in the spiritual essence and then
they would take over another host body
or their physical body would
reconstitute itself by way of like a
healing factor or something along those
lines but jumping to the 1800s or so
there was a guy in London by the name of
Nathaniel Essex and Nathaniel Essex was
this guy he was obsessed with human
biology
he knew that there were mutants who were
living among them the mutants didn't
know what they were these external had
no idea what they were but Nathaniel
Essex believe that they were mutations
and they were basically harbingers of a
not too far-flung future when human
beings will begin to disappear and would
basically move out of the way for these
mutants to rise to prominence the Daniel
Essex hypothesized that mutants would
have a wide array of different powers
everything from telepathy and
telekinesis to the ability to work
reality on a universal scale the problem
with this is that Nathaniel Essex
colleagues considered him to be crazy
they kicked him out of the Royal Academy
of Sciences all that kind of good stuff
now eventually Nathaniel Essex is met by
apocalypse and apocalypse you know is
intrigued by what Nathaniel Essex is
doing and says harken alas I will give
you immortality if you will continue
your studies and basically keep me
abreast of what it is that you're doing
and so the Daniell Essex was modified by
the technology of Apocalypse and when
or word as mr. sinister now skip past
all this and let's jump to the outbreak
of world war two we're kind of doing a
whole lot of you know jumps here man but
we're jumping to the outbreak of world
war two with sublime sitting down and
realizing that the more mutants there
were popping up the more his dominance
of the planet Earth is being challenged
sublime basically came to the conclusion
that a fighting force needed to be
created for the purpose of eliminating
mutants in their entirety and so what
John sublime did is create a program
called weapons plus and weapons plus was
basically going to be the first step or
is going to be this umbrella company
that was designed for the purpose of
just finding different ways to create
super soldiers and different things like
that now at the same time that this was
competeing mr. sinister Nathaniel Essex
had taken up residence in the Auschwitz
concentration camp where he was
basically experimenting on prisoners
that were taken by the Nazis during
World War two he was conducting all
kinds of experiments you know where he
was analyzing the genes of normal humans
he was analyzing the genes of mutants
who were captured he was trying to
figure out what caused his humans to
turn into mutants what this extra gene
is trying to discover this stuff of
course he documented all of his work in
a journal but the issue was that on the
American front back in the United States
John sublime was still looking for a way
to create future soldiers and so word
had reached the ears of Sablan that a
German scientist named Abraham Erskine
had developed a serum that could create
super soldiers and so what John sublime
did was have Sergeant Nick Fury and his
Howling Commandos basically you know
travel into Germany extract Abraham
Erskine and bring him to the United
States now John Sablan never interacted
with Erskine Erskine never knew who John
sublime' was all Erskine knew was that
he was basically working for the US
government to create super soldiers
himself after going through a whole list
of candidates eventually Abraham Erskine
settled on Steve Rogers Steve Rogers
went to a super soldier program and he
became Captain America the issue was at
any eyes of sublime Captain America was
a complete and total failure and the
reason why was because Captain America
was supposed to be the first in a line
of super soldiers that would basically
serve the ultimate purpose of killing
off mutants across the planet Earth but
because of Captain America's moral code
and that he didn't kill he didn't
torture
John Sablan considered him to be a
failure and so because list and because
Abraham Erskine had been killed by the
Nazis
no one was able to duplicate the secret
soldier serum which john Sablan intended
to do to basically duplicate the serum
and then go back to the drawing board
creating like a conditioning program
that would make a new Steve Rogers but
he would basic
function under the direction of John
sublime without any measure of a moral
compass and so what's the blind did
realizing the film couldn't be
duplicated if you basically sent one of
his guys to begin looking around for
ways to kind of advance and keep the
super-soldier program going now while
these guys were hunting around for the
Super Soldier Serum Captain America was
off just being a hero right I mean oh
those were all Captain America stories
where he was fighting against you know
all the forces of Hydra and the Nazis or
so on and so forth but his journeys
eventually took him to what kondeh the
reason why was because of the fact that
remember
Lokhande holds vibranium and Adolf
Hitler Red Skull Baron von Strucker a
handful of others had come to the
realization that if Nazi Germany had
wakanda's vibranium the weapons they
could create would make them virtually
indestructible and so when they went to
invade Wakanda the United States
responded particularly Captain America
Bucky Barnes name of the Submariner and
Jim Hammond the original Human Torch
operating as the superhero group the
invaders they helped to fight off the
Hydra and Nazi soldiers and the result
was that Captain America basically
received a few things for his work the
first is that he came to the realization
that the wakandan soldiers were using
round shields instead of the iron shaped
shield he had that so Captain America
said well I mean they're more
aerodynamic they can be used offensively
and defensively and so they cut that
Captain America after receiving a shard
of vibranium as thanks from the king of
Wakanda a baton went back to the United
States and told the government that he
wanted a new shield that was going to be
round enter a guy by the name of Myron
McLain Myer McLain was a metallurgist
that worked for the US government and
what the US government did is they said
Captain America wants a new shield
composed of this material called
vibranium make this shield for him and
so Myron McLain began the process about
building this shield the issue was that
he literally fell asleep while he was
making it and when he woke up he
discovered that some unknown compound
had mixed with the vibranium and the
result was that he basically came across
this indestructible shield now we know
now in Marvel Comics that the materials
were basically iron and steel but at the
time Myer McLain didn't know that and so
the result was that Maya McLain tried to
find a way to recreate Captain America's
shield and in doing so accidentally
stumbled across at a mansion now with
regards to the whole aspect of Wolverine
getting involved into the fray wow this
was being made and adamantium is
being discovered and so on and so forth
the guys that were basically working for
John sublime had stumbled across the
journals of mr. sinister with in
Auschwitz after the concentration camp
him
liberated by Captain America Bucky
Barnes and so on they took the journals
back to John sublime and weapons Plus
and they began creating more weapons
programs weapons 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 using
the information and mr. senator's
journal beats weapons projects included
everything ranging from bonding animals
with cybernetic implants to giving
people pills that would send them into a
frenzy and you know increase their
strength and speed so on and so forth
but none of them came anywhere close to
duplicating Captain America's Super
Soldier Serum and so because of this
weapons fuss began to shift its focus
and so in the early 1960s when Spiderman
was first popping up when Peter Parker
was being bitten by a radioactive spider
when the Fantastic Four were going into
space being blasted with cosmic rays
when Tony Stark was being taken prisoner
in Vietnam and building the Iron Man
suit there was a group that was
operating as a joint venture between the
United States's CIA and Canada's
clandestine organization Department K
this group was called Team X and they
basically carried out black ops missions
what would happen is the CIA would use
Team X operating out of Canada to send
them on various missions as a buffer and
what this means is that if Team X were
to fail if they were to be caught then
basically the CIA could devolve itself
they could walk away and they could say
well look we had nothing to do with that
that was all candidates Department K but
word had repeat years of John savlon
that one of the members of Team X was
basically healing from every single
injury that he had of course this person
being Logan and because of this with
Team X basically being part of the CIA
the team was absorbed by weapons Plus
and the various individuals that was
part of the team were brought in as part
of the new weapons pen or Weapon X
project and so what happened is
Wolverines was basically forced into the
adamantium bonding process because of
its healing factor the bonding process
was successful the issue with it as we
know almost immediately after this
bonding process was completed he
basically broke out of its containment
pod or whatever it is using the various
trainings on the fact that he was very
much in the state of animal madness he
essentially killed everybody who was
there and then took off of course this
leads into the origin of X 23 but I hope
this made sense to you guys I thought it
was a pretty cool topic to kind of talk
about the origin of Wolverines
adamantium more or less but uh yeah it's
a really interesting set of
because there's so many things that go
into there's so many aspects that sort
of lead up to this thing but if you guys
are new here to comment explain race you
guys should have sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later please
[Music]